sometimes our cellphones don't last very
long after just ten months of busted
screen I'm on the hunt for a new cell
phone
on average Germans buy a new cell phone
every two years in 2013 around 30
million cell phones were sold in Germany
but which one is the right one to buy my
criteria the materials have to be
environmentally friendly and the workers
paid a fair wage so I'm looking for a
new cell phone it should have the latest
technology if possible but it should
also be environmentally sustainable what
do you recommend I can tell you about
the phone's technology and about the
manufacturing company but I can't tell
you where the different components come
from unless it's from Apple their phones
come from China is there no such thing
as a Fairtrade cell phone maybe someone
at another store knows more have you
ever heard of a Fairtrade cell phone no
idea no but I can guess what it is
something like Fairtrade coffee
apparently it's easier to make Fairtrade
coffee than it is to make a Fairtrade
cell phone the German NGO German watch
has tried to figure out why production
lines for cell phones are so complicated
where is the problem fair trade
chocolate and coffee are consumed
directly by the end buyer but as many as
30 different metals are needed to make a
cell phone it all starts with mining the
materials then there's the production
process most often done in Asia
discarded phones frequently end up in
Africa where heavy metals inside the
phones can harm the environment what do
you recommend I do with this cell phone
it's difficult we tell people that it's
important to use your cell phone as long
as possible there's also a new type of
cell phone coming on the market that is
really interesting a so-called fair
phone this phone tries to address some
of these problems the name sounds
promising my search takes me to the land
of tulips coffee shops and canals the
cell phone company fair phone is based
in Amsterdam it's environmentally
friendly your phone is making headlines
around the world fair phone has just
delivered its first twenty five thousand
phones so we've been able to identify
two of the minerals in the phone tin and
tantalum that they come from or at least
we've joined an initiative that is
working in the Democratic Republic of
Congo and has comes from certified
conflict-free certified mines but the
other 28 minerals at this point we
cannot trace because that's the problem
in the industry at the moment is that
the tracking and tracing of minerals has
become so difficult I don't think
there's any such thing as a fair phone
at this point in the industry it's
impossible to trace back where our
minerals come from and the other thing
is there's a question what is 100% fair
anyway so no so our phone I wouldn't say
that it's a fair phone it's it's a
starting point to start changing the way
things are made a fair phone that isn't
completely fair I'd rather head back to
Berlin without a new phone my search for
a new phone is over for now
I would like to have my phone repaired
the solution instead of buying a new
phone
get a new screen its environmentally
friendly fare and for 70 euros
relatively cheap let's turn it on it
works super after 2 days of running
around my cell phone works again let's
hope it stays that way
but I won't be able to buy a truly fair
cellphone for a while